[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
2022 has been a year of change for
Australia you have all heard about the
latest one following the death of
Elizabeth II Charles III has also become
the new Head of State for the land of
kangaroos and surfing however the truth
is that the largest island in the world
always throws a curveball in the 70s
Charles tried to be appointed governor
general of Australia and was
unsuccessful once married to Diana of
Wales his first great trip abroad took
them to the Pacific and it is said that
it was precisely in Australia where
Prince Charles's jealousy towards lady
dye's popularity began then in the 90s
he suffered an attack in Sydney in the
style of Christina Fernandez de
kirschner so don't be surprised if
Australians are once again making King
Charles's life miserable because
republicanism is on the rise in this
country
[Music]
well the truth is that they already
tried to do away with the monarchy in
1999 when they held a referendum for
establishing a republic although on that
occasion the monarchy prevailed but
since Charles III is not Elizabeth II
nobody can rule out that the Republicans
will return to The Fray in the next few
years what is already a reality for the
time being is that may 2022 also saw a
significant shift in Australian politics
Albanese to be PM as labor ousts
Australian conservatives after a decade
in power a lot has changed in Australia
over these nine years and things have
also changed in the world for example
there is a worldwide agreement to fight
global warming a worldwide pandemic
killed 6.5 million people and
visualpolitik is about to reach 1.3
million subscribers which we'll talk
about soon and on this channel we have
dedicated several videos to the tensions
between Australia and China relations
between the island continent of Oceana
and the Asian giant have deteriorated
significantly in recent years however it
now appears that the new government of
Anthony Albanese is betting on adopting
an entirely different strategy for
dealing with China so the question is
what will this shift to the left in
Australia translate into how might this
change of government affect canberra's
relations with Beijing today on
visualpolitik we are going to provide
answers to these questions but first
let's take a look at a bit of History
from climate change to policy change
the United Kingdom has the reputation
but the real crusher of prime ministers
is Australia in the last 12 years six
different people have been in office and
at least half of them have been toppled
for trying to implement measures to
combat climate change as long as 13
years ago Labor's Kevin Rudd tried to
pass an emissions trading scheme that
was shot down by none other than the
greens who felt that stronger policies
were needed its failure brought Julia
Gillards to power she promised that her
government would never create a carbon
tax and guess what she passed one just a
year later result her popularity
plummeted and there was a labor debacle
at the polls then the liberal
conservative coalition's time in power
began with Tony Abbott who rejected the
climate change campaign Point Blank he
was followed by Malcolm Turnbull who
like Rudd was ousted by his own party
colleagues because of his plans to push
for zero emissions energy so you can see
that this is a particularly sensitive
issue in Australia
fossil fuels are Australia's great
source of wealth the island continent
has become the world's largest exporter
of coal with a 29 share of the global
market in addition Australia has been a
major beneficiary to the liquefied
Natural Gas Revolution its gas
production has tripled in the last 10
years and the country has become the
world's largest exporter of LNG with a
more than 20 share of all World exports
you could say it's a real money-making
machine
but the exploitation of Australia's
natural resources does not end there
mining accounts for 11 of GDP and
generates 270 000 direct jobs what's
more while the world has been talking
for years about Concepts such as energy
transition or decarbonization of the
economy in Oz half of the electricity is
still generated with coal take a look
Well visualpolitik Community this is the
reality of Australia fossil fuels are
part of what many call the Australian
way of life so no one has wanted to do
anything to change it until suddenly a
series of natural disasters have brought
the environments to the Forefront of the
political news
in recent years Australia has suffered
all kinds of catastrophes between 2019
and 2020 Australia suffered a wave of
fires that swept through more than 24
million hectares an area of land
equivalent to the entire United Kingdom
it is estimated that the damage exceeded
60 billion more recently in February of
2022 Australia experienced one of the
worst floods in its history with 22
deaths and 3 billion dollars in losses
in addition half of its most precious
and best-known natural treasure the
Great Barrier Reef has died as a result
of warming ocean temperatures
foreign
all these developments have made the
environment a national concern and today
if we talk about the environment we're
talking about the debate about global
warming the thing is that all of a
sudden all of this has had a huge
electoral impact in fact what cost prime
minister Scott Morrison his job was
precisely not doing much of anything
for buzzworld in Australia is teal it
means blue green and the teals are the
independent candidates who in several
constituencies have ended to the
traditional dominance of the liberal
conservative Coalition they are
so-called because ideologically they
could be perfectly placed on the
Australian right but they are calling
for stronger action against global
warming thereby claiming that concern
for the environment is not the exclusive
Preserve of the political left
the rise of the teals put an end to
Morrison's chances for a second turn and
now it is the turn of Labor's Anthony
Albanese or albo as the new Australian
prime minister is also known
[Music]
for example in early September 2022 it
secured passage of legislation raising
Australia's 2030 emissions reduction
commitment from 2005 from 28 to 43 this
new law is a big turnaround from
Australia's traditional approach so now
what no one doubts is that the Oceana
giant is going to need a lot of
investment in the coming years
Australia's labor party has 82
Renewables goal for 2030. in 2021
Renewables generated 29 of Australia's
electricity so there is a long way to go
in this area otherwise albo's economic
program offers nothing that could not be
found in that of any labor politician
anywhere for example he wants better
social services and to raise the minimum
wage by five percent however it seems
that much more important for the
Australian economy will be whether or
not albo succeeds in bringing relations
with China back on track so the question
is how is Australia's new government
moving forward listen up
[Music]
the saw
[Music]
Australia and China have had trade
relations since the 19th century but it
was with the Awakening of the Asian
Giants that economic ties between the
two countries grew at an impressive Pace
Australia has everything and Beijing
wants it we are talking about food coal
natural gas iron and all kinds of
minerals the Chinese economy devours
every resource at its disposal and
Australia has been more than happy to
provide it ten years ago China had
already become its largest trading
partner and then suddenly the Australian
authorities were caught in a complicated
Balancing Act the world's largest island
was basing its Prosperity on trade with
a Communist dictatorship like China
while at the same time its security
remained dependent on its alliance with
the United States and of course China
and the United States have not exactly
been getting along for a few years now
the question now is to put the two
things on a scale Prosperity versus
security the question is which one
carries more importance for you because
the truth is that Australia has always
been very clear about that
foreign
Australia is one of the five members of
the five eyes a us-led intelligence
Alliance that includes the United
Kingdom Canada and New Zealand these
countries consider it a national
security risk to use Chinese
telecommunications companies such as
Huawei to be providers of 5G networks
for this reason Donald Trump pushed for
a veto of Huawei that its allies
including Australia have followed
[Music]
but wait a minute because if there is
one thing that truly angered China it
was that Australia called for an
independent investigation into the
origins of covid-19 and guess what
beijing's response was unprecedented
[Music]
it published a list of 14 complaints
about Australia the list complained
about the veto on Huawei and its
insinuations about covid-19 but also
about other issues such as Australia
rejecting its claims over the South
China Sea or blaming China for being
behind cyber attacks this was what the
Communist Regime put on the table what
remained hidden was the implementation
of an unofficial trade embargo that has
remained in place to this day suddenly
Australian products stopped being bought
by China except for those such as iron
ore and liquefied natural gas because at
the end of the day it is more
complicated to find alternative
suppliers then China publicly also
failed to complain about something that
also bothers Beijing a lot Australia's
increasing closeness to its Regional
enemies
you see Australia is part of quad a
diplomatic alliance with the United
States India and Japan that has been
conducting the Malabar joint Naval
exercise for precisely two years the
purpose that unites them is to maintain
a free and open indo-pacific a fancy way
for these countries to say that they
have to join forces to counter China's
Ambitions in the region
five eyes quad and for the past year
another Alliance orcas Australia United
Kingdom and United States we have
covered this here on visualpolitik these
countries are expanding their diplomatic
and technological collaboration to
provide Australia with eight
nuclear-powered submarines and to
jointly develop supersonic missiles for
the Oceana giant orcus represents a
change of strategy these new submarines
will give it two things first greater
capacity to operate in the shipping
lanes between the Strait of Malacca and
Taiwanese Waters and second it will be
able to launch much longer range
missiles in practice this will position
it as an international power however
orcas's biggest critics believe that
this agreement puts U.S interests first
and unnecessarily provokes China but in
Australia they don't think so
there is a strong consensus around orcas
and in fact Australians believe that the
country should invest more in its Armed
Forces so labor coming to power is not
going to change anything what the change
of government has brought is an
opportunity to resume diplomatic
contacts China's Envoy to Australia says
two Nations at new juncture several
weeks after the Australian elections
came to the Thor the defense and foreign
Ministers of the two countries met
marking the first high-level talks in
more than two years there is even
speculation that the new prime minister
May soon meet Xi Jinping China insists
that there are many reasons for the
Asian giant and the Oceana giant to be
friends and partners rather than enemies
and adversaries the Prime Minister
Albanese is demanding more than just
fine words from China he wants facts and
right now that means restoring the old
trade ties between the two what's in
China's interest to lift all of the
sanctions against Australia and it's in
Australia's interest for that to happen
as well I want to cooperate with China
where we can I'll stand up for
Australia's interests where we must
there is no justification for these
sanctions on Australian products and
they all should be lifted the question
is is China willing to lift them
well it seems that Beijing right now is
worried that sanctions on Russian coal
will increase competition to buy this
mineral in international markets this
could mean higher prices and
difficulties in maintaining Supply so
this favors China being willing to buy
coal from Australia again and lift part
of the current sanctions but wait a
minute because there is another issue
that could greatly increase the tension
between the Asian giant and the Oceana
giant well what exactly am I talking
about well let's take a look at it
[Music]
the Judgment of Solomon
[Music]
orcus was like a direct torpedo of those
who thought that Australia China
relations could be easily redirected XI
jinping's regime raised its voice and
criticized Australia for betting on
entering an arms race however don't
think Beijing has stood still it has
targeted smaller Pacific Nations many
countries in the region have ties with
the United States Australia and New
Zealand but China is tempting them with
a full trade Aid and investment package
so it was only a matter of time before
some such news broke China sane Security
deal with Solomon Islands alarming
neighbors under this agreement the
Solomon Islands could ask China to send
police and soldiers to help maintain
order provide humanitarian Aid and also
to perform any other tasks agreed by
both parties
on the other hand China could send its
ships to call at the Solomon Islands
when needed but always with local
approval on the table is always the
question that this agreement could be
the first step for China to establish a
military base in this archipelago so it
is also true that we could argue about
the Strategic value of such an isolated
Outpost in any case what is certain is
that China has scored a point and that
this agreement set off the alarm bells
in Australia the Morrison government put
pressure on the Solomon Islands to
prevent it from signing the agreement
but failed now it's up to labor to
manage the situation
foreign
[Music]
Albanese has said that he has a
comprehensive plan for the Pacific the
new prime minister wants to boost
Australia's assistance to its
neighboring countries he has two
mechanisms to do this more diplomacy and
above all more money labor is committed
to increasing Aid to Pacific island
countries and East Tibor by 525 million
dollars
the point is that after the Solomon
Islands China went after the entire
Pacific its goal was clear persuade 10
countries to sign a regional agreement
covering trade and security China went
so far as to make its proposals public
but not all of them Beijing talked about
providing scholarships training medical
assistance but not a word about its
security proposals what China did not
count on was that its worst enemy would
be China itself
many Pacific leaders are disturbed by
China's interest in linking economic and
security proposals in this vein David
panuelo president of Micronesia sent a
letter warning his neighbors that the
common development Vision agreement
could allow China to conduct massive
surveillance in the region look at what
he told them the common development
Vision threatens to bring a new Cold War
era at best and a World War at worst
David panuelo president of the Federated
States of Micronesia so China failed and
did not succeed in making this major
agreement Prosper it did get less
important ones with Samoa and Tonga but
the truth is that Australia is now
getting its act together and is
maneuvering a diplomatically in fact it
is given a boost to its relations with
Fiji and also concluded an eight-year
partnership to boost development with
Samoa itself it is also moving to get
more engagement from Washington with the
region and guess what it looks like the
Biden Administration has picked up the
gauntlet U.S Australia and allies form
new Pacific island partnership we're
talking about the partners in the Blue
Pacific initiative
[Music]
New Alliance announced in June that aims
to help Pacific island nations address
everything from economic and climate
change to more security related issues
this is undoubtedly the West's response
to China's growing interest in the
region but now the questions are for you
do you think diplomacy will be enough to
curb China's influence in the Pacific
what should the new Australian
government do you can leave me your
answers in the comments as always if you
found the video interesting please like
it and don't forget to subscribe to
visualpolitik all the best I'll see you
next time
[Music]
foreign